Бульбашки газу на поверхні моря.
Так виглядає район витоку на газопроводах "Північний потік"
очима берегової охорони Данії.
Руйнування зазнали обидві нитки "Північного потоку"
і однієї з двох ниток "Північного потоку-2".
Першою відреагувала данська влада.
Прем'єр-міністерка Данії Метте Фредеріксен
одразу припустила, що руйнування невипадкові:
Саботаж ми не можемо виключати.
Поки що рано робити висновки,
але це надзвичайна ситуація.
Це не звичайна ситуація. І є три витоки.
Навіть за певної відстані один від одного.
І саме тому важко уявити, що це збіг.
Пізніше із офіційними заявами виступили шведські політики.
Виконувачка обов'язків прем'єр-міністра Швеції
Магдалена Андерсон зазначила, що Стокгольм
прийняв до відома інформацію, передану данськими колегами,
і на її основі дійшли висновку,
що мова може йти про саботаж:
Обидва Північні потоки не належать ані Швеції, ані Данії,
так що це не напад на шведську або данську територію.
Але уряд дуже серйозно ставиться до того, що сталося,
не в останню чергу у світлі поточної ситуації з безпекою
в нашій країні та сусідньому регіоні.
Водночас міністр закордонних справ Польщі Збігнєв Рау
заявив, що це може бути елементом
гібридної війни Росії проти НАТО:
Звичайно, має бути розпочате міжнародне розслідування.
Але якщо ви запитуєте мене про мою особисту думку,
я можу вам сказати, що час цих трьох вибухів,
так би мовити, дуже важливий.
Росія втратила оперативну ініціативу на землі в Україні.
Водночас запрацював газогін Baltic Pipe.
Вибухи сталися дуже близько до територіальних данських вод,
але не в територіальних данських водах,
тому що в цьому випадку це було б вторгненням на територію НАТО.
Західні експерти одностайні в тому,
що в даному випадку йдеться як мінімум
про диверсійну діяльність.
Звичайно, коли три витоки на двох газопроводах
відбуваються протягом 24 годин, це дивно.
І це настільки дивно, що починаєш замислюватися
і запитувати: "А чи не саботаж це?"
Так, це могло б бути аварією.
Якби стався лише один витік.
Але якщо взяти до уваги той факт,
що витоків було три, причому сталися вони майже
одночасно, то, ймовірно, йдеться про саботаж".
У тому, що здійснити такий диверсійний акт
можуть лише структури на державному рівні,
теж майже ніхто не сумнівається:
Коли бачиш, на якому рівні складності з технічного погляду
здійснено ці атаки, то розумієш, що, швидше за все,
в цьому замішаний державний суб'єкт.
І в Балтії є лише один державний суб'єкт...
у якого можливості та мотивація сходяться воєдино.
І це, очевидно, Росія.
Але якою є мотивація, з якою метою Кремль
руйнує створені ним же енерготранспортні комунікації?
Ну, про це можна міркувати, але однією з можливих цілей
Росії може бути стратегічний сигнал НАТО та Заходу,
щоб показати: дивіться, ми здатні маніпулювати
встановленою на морському дні критичною інфраструктурою,
здатні її зруйнувати.
Росія використовує газ як важіль тиску на Захід
через війну в Україні. У цьому сенсі вона намагається
підірвати нашу волю, спрямовану на підтримку України,
тому що вона може обійтися нам занадто дорого.
Варто замислитися над тим, чи не вигідно Росії
спробувати ще більше дестабілізувати європейський енергетичний ринок?
Іншою причиною може бути, наприклад,
внутрішньополітичний наратив, у якому Путін може
спробувати продати всередині країни цю диверсію
як напад Заходу на російську газову експортну інфраструктуру,
щоб розкрутити цей наратив, який він уже давно
розкручує всередині країни, а саме:
що Захід несе для Росії масивну загрозу,
що Захід вкрай зацікавлений у послабленні Росії,
у тому, щоб вона залишалася слабкою у довгостроковій перспективі.
І саботаж власної трубопровідної інфраструктури, наприклад,
також вписується у цей наратив.
У свою чергу, Москва заперечує свою причетність до того,
що сталося. Прес-секретар Путіна Дмитро Пєсков
назвав подібні версії (цитата) "досить передбачуваними
та передбачувано дурними".
При цьому в російському МЗС заявили,
що саме Вашингтон повинен відповісти, чи не стоїть він
за витіканням газу, оскільки 7 лютого Джо Байден говорив:
якщо Росія вторгнеться в Україну, "Північному потоку" - кінець.
Зі свого боку, Єврокомісія вже попередила,
що заподіяння шкоди європейській енергетичній
інфраструктурі спричинить санкції.
На Заході, зокрема у Берліні, свідомі можливості подальших атак
на енергетичну інфраструктуру ЄС.
Навіть якщо конкретних вказівок на конкретні загрози
об'єктам інфраструктури наразі немає.
За оцінкою правоохоронних органів, можна виходити з існування
абстрактної загрози для об'єктів критичної інфраструктури
і, зокрема, для об'єктів енергетики.
Причому не лише після цього інциденту, а раніше,
особливо від початку війни. Енергетична інфраструктура
знаходиться у особливому фокусі.
І тому правоохоронні органи тут особливо пильні.
У розслідуванні інциденту візьмуть участь Збройні сили,
берегова охорона, морська влада, енергетичні агенції та поліція
одразу кількох країн, включаючи Швецію, Німеччину та Данію.
Ці країни також розраховують на допомогу НАТО у цьому розслідуванні.
На тлі останніх подій багато хто запитує: що далі?
Що тепер буде з "Північним потоком"?
Відбувається витік гігантських обсягів газу.
Можливо, це кілька мільйонів кубометрів на годину.
Труби спорожняються, але мине ще кілька днів,
перш ніж вони повністю спорожніють.
Наскільки швидко можна буде відремонтувати
щось подібне, ще доведеться з'ясувати.
"Газпром", наприклад, уже заявив,
що у них зараз зв'язані руки в усіх відношеннях,
тому що вони не можуть провести розслідування
або, перш за все, ремонт через західні санкції.
Це також говорить про Росію як про причину,
вона тепер передає м'яч назад Заходу
та його санкційній політиці.
Якщо ви хочете отримати роз'яснення
і якщо ви хочете, щоб трубопровід був відновлений,
то, звичайно, все це має йти рука об руку
з хоча б частковим ослабленням санкцій.
Експерти звертають увагу на той факт, що подібні диверсії -
випадок безпрецедентний та чіткого плану дій для подібних ситуацій не існує.
І все ж, влада Данії вже вжила низку екстрених заходів:
Данське морське відомство та данські військові встановили
зону безпеки з радіусом близько 5 морських миль,
трохи менше 10 кілометрів. Необхідно триматися подалі
від цієї зони, оскільки існує ризик втрати плавучості суден
через газ у воді, а також, природно, ризик вибуху,
оскільки ми маємо справу із чистим газом.
У той же час багато експертів звертають увагу на те,
що перш за все необхідно видалити газ,
що залишився, з трубопроводів:
Я вважаю, що найголовніше зараз -
це видалити залишки газу з трубопроводу,
тобто зробити це треба як з російської сторони,
так і з німецької сторони в Лубміні.
Але, звісно, спочатку треба домовитись із власниками,
з "Газпромом". І я сподіваюся, що "Газпром",
принаймні, у цьому випадку поводитиметься відповідально.
Німецькі екологи вказують на катастрофічні наслідки
таких масштабних витоків газу для навколишнього середовища.